[GUITAR STRUM]
I have great pleasure to
introduce our first speaker
today.
He is my colleague, a
good friend of mine,
and so without further ado,
I'd like us all to join me
in welcoming Alex Gold.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey, everybody.
Like Kelly said,
my name is Alex.
I'm here to talk today about end
to end data science deployment.
With R Markdown, Shiny,
Plumber, and Pins.
The slides and code
are available online,
at rstd.io/deploy2020.
Although as I'm saying this,
I'm realizing that the slides
are not there yet.
But they will be, so
look forward to that.
So this story starts,
as all great stories
do, with a Shiny app.
And this Shiny
app in particular,
uses the Capital Bikeshare data.
So if you don't know what
the Capital Bikeshare--
is the system of docked
bicycles in Washington DC.
That's what they look like.
That's what the docs look like.
You can rent a bike
from a dock and ride it
to a different dock,
and dock it there.
And so you know, what I'm going
to try and do with this Shiny
app, is predict the number of
bikes, at different stations,
at different times.
So where's my window?
Here's my window.
So this is what
the app looks like.
I've got a map of Washington DC.
I can click on a
particular station.
You'll see this is at 21st
and M. And if I scroll down,
now I can see the
number of bikes that
are available at that station.
Or predicted to be
available at that station,
throughout the next 24 hours.
Important maybe, if I wanted
to go get a bike in DC
at 8PM tonight, because there
are going to be none, at 21st
and M. Too bad.
So let's talk a little bit
about how this app works.
So the Capital
Bikeshare organization
makes available an API, that
provides real time bike data.
How many bikes at each
station, right now,
available on the API.
And I'm going to import this
using an R Markdown document.
From there, I'm going to
build an XG Boost model,
to do all my prediction for me.
I'm going to do that
also in R Markdown.
I'm going to serve this
model with a Plumber API,
and if you're
interested in Plumber--
I'm not going to talk a lot
more about it right now,
but hang out because like
the rest of this track
is going to be a lot of Plumber.
So that'll be awesome.
And then of course,
I'm serving this
to the client app at the end.
And so I had this app, but
I wanted to take it further.
It just lives on my machine.
I don't want it to walk
my computer to people,
to show them my app.
And so I knew where I wanted
to get to, was you know,
my shiny app is available all
the time to whoever wants it.
The model gets
retrained every day,
like whether is going to
change, different seasons.
I want to be able to have the
model retraining periodically,
and I need to do this data
import every 20 minutes.
It's real time data so like
once it's gone, it's gone.
And so I want to get
those real time data,
pull them in, and store
them somewhere so that I
can do my predictions,
as sort of a time series,
or panel kind of thing.
So I'm there, but that leaves like
a whole bunch of questions.
What should I prioritize?
While I'm doing this, there
all these things that I could
want to do, as I'm trying
to sort of deploy this app,
and add some horsepower.
And these are like hard,
scary, big questions,
and really what they
boil down to is,
is my deployment
sophisticated enough?
Am I doing it for real, or not?
Of course, I then
did what I sometimes
do when I'm
procrastinating, which was
I started watching Star Wars.
Just because, you
know, why not do that?
And you all might
know this guy--
green, big ears, talks funny.
He's the Jedi master
Yoda of course,
and he says this line in the
middle one of the movies--
"size matters not.
Look at me.
Judge me by my size,
do you--" and I thought
this was really appropriate.
Like, if you just sub in the
word sophistication here,
this is a great way
to think of, why
do we care about
deploying Shiny apps?
And of course we care, because
we want to increase value.
We want to provide value.
Sophistication is irrelevant.
Are you providing value?
Is the right question.
And so how do we deploy
to increase value?
How was I going to do that?
There were sort of
three principles
that I took as my
guides, and the first one
was that I wanted to make
my content accessible,
and what that meant is that
people who should have access
to the content, can get
it when they need it,
and somewhere that they
know where to find it.
The second thing
was reproducible.
Can I can I reliably understand
how the content exists?
Why it is the way it is?
Can I sort of, audit it.
And then secure, and that's sort
of the inverse of accessible.
Should people who don't--
people who shouldn't have
access, don't have access.
That's pretty important.
So the question is
how do I get there.
And this is honestly
not a trivial problem.
In particular, in between
those important train
steps with my data, I have
to store that data somewhere.
And then, in between training
and serving the model,
I have to store that
model somewhere.
And until recently this
wasn't a solved problem.
You know, I could put it, the
analysis data in a database,
if I have one handy, if I
have write privileges to one.
That's fine.
But if I don't,
or if I don't want
to put it in a database for
some reason, there kind of,
was no good answer there.
And similarly with modeling.
There was kind of
no good answer.
So I went I went back to Star
Wars, went back to you know,
not working on this, because
that was that was easier.
And of course Yoda came
to my came to my rescue,
yet again, saying, "when
hopeless the task seems,
come out with a
sweet new R Package.
Someone will."
It's inevitable.
You know.
And of course that was true.
The pins pack to the new package
by Javier Luraschi.
He's here at RStudio, and
this is a super cool package.
I'm super excited about it.
Basically, what it lets
you do is take something,
an R object, put
it somewhere else,
and then get it back
when you want it.
This is sort of the essence
of the pins package.
But look let's go into
a little more detail
about exactly how it works.
So I'm going to start off
with my R, my RStudio session,
and I have an object
I want to save.
You can think like a data frame.
It can also be a model.
It could be any sort
of S3 compliant object.
And I have a board
also, and my board
is where I'm going to save it.
Pins currently supports a
bunch of different boards,
so RStudio Connect Kaggle,
GitHub, Azure, Google Cloud
Platform, S3, or a website.
Javier is constantly adding
new boards I will also add.
So if you want something that
isn't here, put it on GitHub
and I'll probably have it done
before the end of conference.
Kind of incredible.
But that aside, it
supports a lot different
places that you put your data.
Great.
So it's really easy
to use as well.
You put your data
onto the board,
with the pins::pin command,
and get it back with
the pins::pin_get command.
Let me show you
how this works, just
to be a little
more concrete here.
So the way this works is
that I've got my pins--
Let me make this
bigger for you all.
Better, easy to see, right?
So I'm going to load
up the pins package.
I'm going to register my
board, in this case I'm
registering RStudio Connect.
This just means this is
a board you can talk to.
To the the R session.
So it's going to register,
takes just a moment.
And then I'm going to pin
my data to the board, right?
It's a pin, whatever the
object is I'm
pining, the name of the object
and the board where it's going.
And it's going.
Taking a moment to load.
And so here I am in
the connections pane.
You can see that, like any
other type of connection,
like a database connection,
it loads up right here.
And if what I pin
is a data frame,
I can actually see
what's going on there.
I can see the different
fields in my data frame,
and I can also go over here,
I can preview the table.
I can see the first 1,000 rows.
This is mtcars, there are
only 32 but, you know.
You could see up to 1,000.
And then if I want
to get the pin back,
I just run this pin_get command,
saving it to a local file,
and now I've got
mtcars back.
To me, this is so, so cool.
Because what's happened
now is, instead
of having to email
around data, or having
to save data somewhere then
tell everybody where it is.
And you know, version 2 final,
actually final, Alex final,
right?
None of that.
The person needs to know
the name of the board,
or the URL of the
board, and they
need to know what the
name of the pin is.
And then what they get
when they do a pin get,
is always the newest version.
This is a thing that's
really exciting,
it's like the newest version is
always available on this pin.
So the question is sort of,
what are good things to pin,
and what are bad things?
Obviously, you don't want to
just like, store every single R
object you've ever
used in a pin.
So some, again,
wisdom from Yoda.
Just before Luke goes off to
fight Vader at Cloud City,
and it's a disa--
anyway.
Before that though,
Yoda gives him
some very, very sage advice.
"Best considered a cache-ing
mechanism, pins are."
And what this means--
A, it's kind of, this
movie came out in 1980,
and this package
came out in 2020.
So like, this is very
impressive to begin with.
But even more impressive
is that he's right.
And so you generally don't want
to save your data of record
in a pin.
It's not a database.
It doesn't have all the
like, bells and whistles
of a database,
being able to audit.
Not a database replacement.
What pins are great for is,
is they're great for something
that you could
compute at the time,
or you could get at the
time, but it's easier
to store it somewhere.
You'd rather cache it, rather
than recreating it on demand.
And so there are
three attributes
that good candidates
for a pin have.
And that is that they're
relatively small,
say like, a gigabyte.
There's no hard
rule, but a gigabyte
is a good rule of thumb.
They're reused.
You actually want this thing
over, and over, and over again,
in different pieces
of your content.
And that they're current.
You want the tip of the pin.
You only care about
the newest version.
If you care about
archival versions,
a pin is not a great choice.
But if you care about just the
newest one, that's really good.
And again, pins are for
things you can recreate.
It's not for your
data of record,
that that's not a great choice.
I mean, if you do it, whatever,
I'm not going to stop you.
But officially
recommending against that.
So let me show you.
Let's go back to our bike
app here, and just show
a little bit of where
pins show up in this app.
We're very zoomed in.
And so here we have the app.
Reminder.
This is what our app looks like.
We've got a map, we
click on the map,
we get the prediction
of the number of bikes,
at different
stations throughout.
And so there are a couple
places that pins show up here.
And I'm going to be very
honest, this app it's
quite-- the code that goes
in here is quite large.
It demos a lot of
different things.
So I'm going to sort
of like, real quick,
do a couple little
things here, and ignore
a lot of the rest of the code.
So that's just how
it's going to go.
Sorry.
And so when I go
to my pins here,
I have my ingest and tidy part.
This is where I'm
pulling in from the API,
so I'm registering with both
my database connection, that's
this line 15, and
in lines 16 and 17,
I'm registering the pins
board, because I'm going to
to put things in both places.
So first what I'm
going to do is,
I'm going to pull down from
the API the number of bikes.
Oh, interesting.
Maybe I should run
this line first.
There we go.
And so what I'm
going to do is, I'm
going to pull down
the number of bikes.
And you can see this is just
a data frame that came back.
All this code in
here is just sort of,
interpreting the API call.
And what I'm doing is, I'm
just pulling in the station ID,
and the number of
bikes available.
These are really sort of, the
most important fields to me.
This is going to
be like my target,
when I'm doing my
machine learning.
And then I'm going to
write this to my database.
That's getting written
to my database,
and that's actually
shed scheduled
to happen on RStudio
Connect every 20 minutes.
So that's great, taken care of.
The next piece, though, and
this is what I'm going to pin.
So this data frame.
This data frame-- this is
the station information.
So this is, it's those IDs.
Those station IDs,
which is numeric.
But I have the names here,
which is what I'm putting-- pop
up there in the app.
I'm putting up the
latitude and longitude,
which I'm going to use both
to put them on the map,
and also as a feature in
my machine learning model.
As well as the capacity
of the station,
which is also an
important feature
of my machine learning model.
And this is a perfect
candidate for a pin.
It's small, it's
less than 600 rows.
I reuse it several
different times
across this piece of
content, and I always
want the most current version.
On my map, I don't
want to be showing
stations that don't
exist, or that have moved,
or anything like that.
And so this is what I'm going
to be pinning in my code.
Similarly, then when I go on
to build my XG Boost model--
again, I'm going to skip a
lot through some code here.
But you can see that I'm
pulling in another pin here.
This is my modeling
parameters actually,
that I'm writing elsewhere.
But what I really want
to show is, down here
I'm training my model
with parsnip xgb_train.
And then what I'm saving
here is this list object.
This is like, this could be a
formal S3 object-- it's not.
It's just a list.
But I have my model.
I'm saving some metadata
with it as well.
The training date,
the splitting date,
between my testing
and training set.
And the recipe that I'm using
from the recipes package,
to actually make
my training data.
And then I'm pinning that
here, onto RStudio Connect.
And this is super useful.
Now I have a really good
way to know what I've done.
And then last, my
Plumber API, that's
serving those predictions.
I've got my model, I'm
reading it in here.
And then all this
code basically,
is just sort of interpreting
the input from the API,
and making sure it's ready
to be fed into the model.
And then down here,
and I'm running
that predict command on that
model, that's from the pin.
And this is you know, purring
away on RStudio Connect.
And so you know, I can come
here to the swagger interface,
and get back.
You know, these are the
predictions for station 75.
I don't know what
station that is,
but that's why I
have the other one.
The other pin with
the station names.
So that's how pins sort
of fit into this app.
So now I've got a
solution for this.
For my analysis data, I can do
it in a database or in a pin,
for my model I can
do it in a pin.
One thing I do want to say
is, these are just slots,
and you can put whatever
you want into these slots.
So for example, if you're
using some model in Python,
or some import method in Python.
You can totally do
that, and use
Reticulate to go back and forth
between R and Python super easily.
If what you're serving is
an a model, if it's plots,
or just some kind of
counting, the same principle
totally works.
And when you're sharing,
if what you've got
is an R Markdown document, that
you want to render or email
out, or something like that.
Again, think of these as slots.
My version happened
to be R Markdown--
R Markdown, Plummer, Shiny app.
But yours can be
whatever you want.
OK, so pins has really
helped me a lot,
make this content more
accessible, more reproducible.
But I haven't really
addressed security at all,
and that's a really
important piece here,
the security of my app.
And so of course, I
went back to Yoda.
In "Return of the
Jedi," as Yoda is dying,
fading away after 800 years
of training Jedi knights,
witnessing the
downfall-- anyway, OK.
I'm sorry, I really
like Star Wars.
He gives this one final
piece of advice to Luke,
and he says, "deploy
to the right server,
and secure your data will be."
Which you know, I think is
very, very prescient of him.
And you can do this
in an open source way,
if you know that's what
you're more comfortable doing.
For this import
and training step,
you know, put it on a server
any server that has R works.
You can use a Cron Job if
you want to schedule it.
For your analysis
data and your model,
you can use-- if you have
a database for the database
stuff, or a pins board.
I showed there are like, a
whole bunch of options.
For serving the model, any
server with R, again, can work.
You do have some things
to be delicate with here,
around how auth works, right?
So you can do that
with networking rules.
You could put a
proxy in front of it.
You can like, route it
through a lambda gateway,
to take care of API keys.
You have lots of
options, but you're
going to want to do
something to secure this API.
And then for sharing you
have a lot of options.
If it's an R Markdown document,
either a website or a rendered
document.
Netlify is a great choice.
Shiny Server open source
is available to you,
and shinyapps.io is
also an option, which
is not open source, but is
relatively affordable, so that
can be a really good
option here, if you
doing like a private
thing, or something
that's for your own use.
Of course, we see a
lot of organizations
that sort of struggle
with pieces of this.
Either they don't want to
manage this many sort of,
separate pieces.
Their IT organizations don't
want to manage stuff in R,
we see that a lot.
That's totally fine.
And so of course, sort
of, easy mode here.
Is our professional
product RStudio Connect,
and that takes care of a
lot of these pieces for you.
It can deal with the API keys.
It can deal with scheduling
the R Markdown documents.
It can deal with securing
the Plumber APIs.
It can deal with
accessibility controls
and that kind of stuff,
and you can put pins
on RStudio Connect.
So this can be a really
useful way to do all of this.
So big takeaways.
When you are thinking
about deploying content,
the top three things to
really optimize for are--
accessibility,
reproducibility, and security.
If you're hitting
these three keys,
you're probably
increasing value with what
you're doing, as opposed to
just adding sophistication.
While you're doing
that, R Markdown,
Shiny, Plumber and Pins,
are good friends of yours.
And of course, may
the force be with you.
Thanks everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
I failed to mention at
the top of things here,
but if you have questions, we're
going to continue using Sli.do,
as we did in the keynote.
So we're in Grand Ballroom
B, so if you have a question,
go to the same Sli.do page,
select Grand Ballroom B
and you can enter your questions
there, or vote on questions
that are already asked there.
I'm going to ask
Alex some questions
here, since we have
a couple minutes.
Maybe this was covered in the
last half of your presentation,
but do you want
to readdress, how
pins is different from a well
organized shared file system,
with correct ACLs?
Yeah, that's a great question.
To be honest, under the hood
it's not that different, right?
You have got the same kind of,
control and access controls.
The main difference is that
it's a very R centric answer,
and so you can, from within
R, address those objects,
without having to go through
the hassle of figuring out how
your shared file system works.
Finding things and
that sort of thing.
So from an IT perspective,
maybe not that different.
But from the perspective
of an R developer,
it's a very different sort
of, development experience.
It's much more straightforward.
This next one, we get a lot.
So I'm happy to ask
it here-- what's
the benefit of using a Plumber
API for saving the object to S3
and then calling it
with a Shiny app?
Oh, that's a great question.
I love that question.
There are a couple of benefits.
One is that you can--
the biggest benefit
to me, and then this
happened in several
different ways,
is that it decouples the
logic of serving the model,
from the logic of displaying
whatever you're displaying,
or doing something else with it.
So you decouple those
things, and that
makes your life easier.
It makes your life easier
in a couple of ways.
One of them is purely
from a code perspective--
it makes it easier
to write the code,
because you write your Plumber
API to serve the model.
You write your Shiny
app, or whatever it is,
to consume the model
and you get to sort of,
separate those concerns,
which is really nice.
The other piece from a
performance perspective--
you can test those two
things independently.
You can test the Plumber
API with say, the load test
package, which I think
some people might
be talking about next.
And then you can test
the Shiny app separately.
You can decouple both the coding
and the performance issues,
between the API and the
app, which is great.
OK, next.
Is there a limit to
the amount of data
you should be using with pins?
It depends on which
board you're using.
Some of those boards do
have limits to how much
you can save.
You know, my suggestion would
be that, if you're saving more
than a gigabyte's worth of
data, there's probably a better
solution for what you're doing.
And that's totally a rule
of thumb, not a real thing.
But just in general, if you're
finding yourself doing more
than that, you're
probably saving
an object that's bigger than
pins really is designed for.
One thing that
can be helpful is,
if you're saving model objects,
often the model objects package
up a lot of stuff with it, that
you don't necessarily want,
like the training data.
And that could make
your model really big,
and you know, sort
of inflate the size.
There is a package called
Butcher, like you know,
person who makes meat cuts,
that you can use to sort of,
chop out some of the
stuff in your model
object you don't want, and just
save like actually the model.
So if you're saving models, that
can be a useful thing to do.
Let's do one more here, I
like this one as well.
Is there a reason your
import and model training
code is in R Markdown files,
instead of plain R scripts.
Yes, that's a great question.
I love it when things that
I put in the presentation
and then took out, because
I didn't have time,
come back in questions.
Yeah, so I really love R
Markdown for two main reasons.
One is that it encourages
literate programming that
is interspersing code and
prose, because you have just
like, a place to write prose.
It doesn't have to be
comments, you just write it
and it's great.
The other reason, is that you
have a record of what you did.
So when you come back later,
and something has gone awry
with your model, you
have output there,
with the code of what
actually happened.
Unlike if it's just
an R script and then,
whatever happened was
totally ephemeral,
and it's gone forever.
Everyone, please join me
in thanking Alex again.
Thanks everybody.
[GUITAR STRUM]